hello everyone and welcome back to the
World Chess Championship match between
yaniponishi and the dingler and we are
already in game 13 which is a success in
itself because for the last 19 years
almost 20 in 2004 was the match Peter
leko versus Vladimir kramnik where uh 14
games were played in the end the the the
match and the Seven uh seven to seven uh
and uh after uh yesterday's game it was
a it was an absolute roller coaster no
one could predict what would happen in
that one and especially that blunder by
nepo that F5 move I will definitely
haunt them for for a very long time it's
now a time to come back into the match
two more games in the classical section
until we go into rapid tie breaks and
what it means for for the players is uh
Fabiano Corona put his best now players
should just put themselves into the
mindset of this being a two-game
classical match and then after that they
are going into rapid tie break so forget
everything that happened so far don't
forget uh you know the the positions and
what you've analyzed because they might
repeat but they will try uh of course
the you know forget the mistakes of the
past so that being said let's check it
out that this is a game 13 the first
ceremonial move was made by this
gentleman here uh of course I forgot to
uh
uh to make it a bit smaller sorry about
that uh yeah the OBS interface is always
super weird I'm sure there's a shortcut
to do this I just never never checked uh
so here we go there we go all right so
the the ceremony ceremonial first move
was made by this gentleman here uh it is
uh Jenny's casingbeck the Akim or the
mayor of Astana and as you can see he is
very very serious about it I think it's
an E4 move uh Nepal looking at it a bit
like uh okay I was definitely planning
on playing E4 here so I'm gonna stick
with that so that being said uh let's
check it out nipple does go with Ponte
E4 and I'm sure you guys are wondering
uh sorry about that
uh will we see another rui Lopez or will
be it will be uh you know uh amidst this
Rue Lopez see the actual martial attack
but chances are nipple will not allow
this as he's been having a very good
success avoiding the Marshall so here
Pawn to E4 with Ponte five Knight F3
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5 Dory
Lopez is on the board and the A6 Thing
Once Again goes for morphe's defense uh
he that didn't really achieve anything
trying the Berlin so it makes sense to
try this whether or you know the
Marshall happens or not so here Bishop
to A4 Knight to F6 and now uh castles by
uh Nepal with Bishop D7 D3 now avoiding
the Marshall of course uh and the pawn
to B5 Bishop to B3 D6 C3 uh we have
castles and now Ponte H3 Rook do you
want a bit of a more popular move but
okay Pawn to H3 also played quite a lot
Bishop to B7 and now Bishop to E3 and
this is now already a very very rare
continuation by nepo it's been only
played by amateurs the the strongest
player to ever play this movie in this
position was rated uh like maybe maybe
2000 maybe 1900 something uh so uh
unexplored territory definitely in top
tier chess with Knight to A5 and now
Buster back to C2 upon the C5 ding just
playing principal moves um uh that you
would normally see Knight F5 on the C5
then the Knight goes back at some point
uh and uh well it's a it's a question
can white when can white push D4 and
when can black push D5 and the bush pun
B7 of course you hope that one day it
will become a very strong piece knight
beat the D2 We have Rook to E8 and now
Pawn to A4 and it is now basically as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game where at some point Nepal will try
and capture on B5 and then dings B Pawn
might become a little bit weak and
that's why uh ding should consider a
more like maybe Ponte B4 but only
consider it because if one to B4 let's
say you trade here and white would even
gladly capture away from the center here
captures captures and Knight to B3 you
trade uh Knight tier letter captress
captures the bishop is now very strong
but black will clip on to A5
and uh it's a question on whether or not
you should play something like this of
course both black and white will try to
use the C file white might even push the
put the bishop and C4 at some point play
B3 and it's going to be a very very
close setup but I think uh goes against
this he plays Ponte H6 and now uh nepo
again has a lot of choices he can play
uh a cap for some B5 he can just
continue development with Rook D1 or he
could strike in the center with Pawn to
D4 and that is exactly what he does he
plays Spawn to D4 and ding captures e
Captain D4 it doesn't matter whether you
capture with the E Pawn or with the c
Pawn because you're gonna capture with
both C counter C counters and now Knight
captures on D4 you could capture with
the bishop but then the Knight just
attacks it so you have to go back and
doesn't really make sense so Knight
characters on D4 we have Knight to C4
now and already a very exciting position
occurs where the bishop is attacked the
Knight is sort of attack the B2 Pawn is
attacked uh how can nipple go about this
well he trades on C4 another way to do
it he could play something like Queen to
F3 because you can never capture on B2
if you didn't give her capture some B2
uh it's uh it's a trapped Knight just
Rook to B1 attacks the Knight and now
whatever you play let's say Knight
captures on A4 just Bishop captures
ended the bishop on B7 will be hanging
so that's out of the question so instead
after Knight to C4 or rather after this
queen to have to remove uh you would
have to play something like Bishop to f8
and then the game continues captures
captures let's see you capture and B5
Knight captures an E3 Queen captures and
you would get this position uh where
ding would be down upon but he would
have the bishop pair so it's a a
standard trade-off so after Knight the
C4 nipple instead just straight tier
Knight captures and c4b captures and now
Ponta F3 just keeping everything solid
here if he was feeling a bit more
adventurous probably he's not due to
what happened yesterday
uh but he might have gone for something
like Knight to F5 again it's a very uh
uh you know uh discrete line that offers
a pawn sacrifice for some very nice play
let's say Bishop to f8 because you're
you really like your dark Square Bishop
here Rook D1 as you will lose the the
for Pawn there's no question about it
it's attacked three times let's say
Bishop captures Bishop captures and now
Rook captures on e4 and you can play
Bishop to D4 uh you're gonna put some
pressure on that G7 pawn and if we trade
here let's say captures captures and D5
black is up a pawn but white will have
some very nice pressure here against the
G7 Pawn then you bring the Rook to D1
and so on so again it's a trade-off but
okay a pawn to F3 by nipple Bishop to f8
and now Bishop back to F2 uh uh A5 is
the move that everyone wants to play
here and it does make sense once the
Knight moves maybe the bishop can even
come to B6 and you know uh uh that the
pawn belongs on A5 also it clears the A4
Square for the light score reverse
Bishop might try to dislodge The Rook
here and the point is after something
like Pawn to D5 and Bishop to A4 you're
again maybe going into ding's territory
here because ding would sacrifice The
Exchange here no questions asked let's
say Bishop captures an eighth queen
captures and F captures on e4 uh sorry
if captures an E4 Bishop counters you
will get this position where okay you're
up the exchange but the ding has the
bishop pair this bishop is coming to C5
and it's gonna be a heart uh very hard
to defend this so at some point this
Pawn might become weak then the past C
Pawn might become a problem so it's not
the white who's pushing for anything
here so instead just Bishop to F2 and
now onto D5 if you can play it you know
that pretty much in every position this
either equalizes or or gives you a
better position e counters on D5 Knight
captures and now just Bishop to E4 by
nepo are trying to neutralize the strong
Bishop on B7 uh the situation on the
clock is an hour and 14
um
and minutes for Nepal versus an hour and
26 minutes for Ding and here ding went
into a really really long thing because
there is quite a lot to consider here uh
there is uh you could play something
like Rook to B8 seems like um a very
reasonable thing to do go after the B2
Pawn you also might consider something
like Queen to G5 with the idea of
putting the Knight F4 and going for some
sort of a checkmating attack and the
ding spent some 25 minutes maybe a bit
longer and played Rook to E5 here and
it's a move that no one could really
explain uh people said uh that it's a
move that only dink could explain and he
probably will at the press conference
I'm sure someone will ask him what
happens if Rook captures an E5 but that
is uh you know for ding to reveal if uh
if he will be willing to and the problem
is uh Queen to G5 was such a strong
option that it's hard to realize why
ding went against it now you can't
really allow Knight to F4 it's such an
ugly move to make an engine okay give
something like Point H for maybe that
kicks away the queen but you don't feel
comfortable advancing your opponent in
front with the king so let's say you
just straight here let's say Bishop
characters Bishop captures Rook D1 uh
once the bishop to C5 comes again this
does not look good for for white at all
uh but okay ding played Rook to E5 he
has a uh he has a bit of a different
plan uh now comes Rook to C1 Nepal just
says okay I'm just going to develop The
Rook attack the C4 pawn and once you
handle uh that I'm gonna continue the
game so Rook the C8 and now Knight the
E2 and now uh all of the plans the ding
might have had uh don't really work in
this particular setup uh one does and it
it really requires um uh being to to put
his mind to it if you play spawn to F5
here Bishop to D4 is what would happen
and now because it's very similar to
what happened in the game so it's uh
it's very weird the ding didn't go for
this let's say F characters and E4 of
course ding would sacrifice The Exchange
but up the C5 check now winning the
three Square let's say King to H2 or H1
doesn't really matter Knight the E3 now
attacks everything here so of course you
have to trade Queens Queen captures with
check row captures and now your Rook is
hanging let's say Rook after E1 and
again you get this position where uh
nepo is upper Rook but the dink has the
the mighty Bishop pair and uh well let's
see he captures an F3 G captures and
Bishop captures on F3 uh this looks very
very good for black
uh ding decides against it and he
instead plays Queen to A7 again uh now
the problem is that he doesn't even have
this bishop to C5 move and nepo
immediately takes advantage of that he
plays Queen to D4 as long as the queen
was on d8 uh he would have the option of
playing Bishop to C5 and then the queen
on D4 doesn't really do all that much
now the queen on D4 could very well be
the strongest piece on the board we have
Ponta F5 now ding does go for the
exchange sacrifice uh Bishop to G3
attacks the rook and now uh Rook
captures on e4 another thing you could
consider is f captures on e4 and uh
perhaps it was the better try because
after Queen captures an E5 Queen
captures and Bishop captures uh there's
of course e captures on F3 G captures
Bishop to C5 check Bishop to D4 and now
uh it seems like why did you uh go into
all of this if you're gonna lose the
bishop pair you're not there is Knight
the F4 and this is how he could keep the
bishop Fair because the thread is not
captured than E2 with check winning The
Rook here or rather the exchange so
you'd have to capture the Knight then
Bishop captures on D4 with checking G2
and now you have this position where yes
you're down the exchange but the mighty
Bishop pair is fully operational uh so
it would again be a trade-off but again
decides not to go into this one so he
already declined F5 on the previous move
and now that he did play it he declines
to go into this he goes for Rook
captures and E4 instead and it's a
a very different line F capital is an E4
Queen captures an E4 Queen captures F
characters and now just Rook F to D1 uh
Fabi also uh presented a very nice idea
for example if Knights the C3 then
Knights the B4 he thought that you could
play Rook captures and f8 because
there's Bishop to D6 but it doesn't work
because after Captain Rook here Bishop
to D6 attacks the Knight and the Rook uh
the problem is there's always Knights to
D3 and this D3 square is pretty much
what uh keeps Link's position uh
impenetrable in all of the lines that we
can check let's say Bishop captures
Knight captures and now black is either
fine or better so instead after uh f-cat
there's an E4 we have Rook F to D1 uh
just going after that default because
you know Dean wants to put the the
Knight on D3 so at some point if ding
attempts that nepo will have Rook to D7
and he does go for it Knight to B4 Rook
to D7 now a nipple has some 47 minutes
on the clock I think has 40 minutes on
the clock uh so plenty of time for both
as they only need to make 11 more moves
uh we have Bishop to C5 with check uh
King to H2 and now Bishop to C6 attacks
The Rook so you're never in time to
capture on C4 Rook the C7 forces a trade
here captures captures and now
uh after captures just Bishop to D5
guarding the pawns here and ding does
have the past E Pawn so it doesn't
really matter that he is down the
exchange he has compensation Knights the
C3 and now Knights the D3 attacks The
Rook here Rook to see to end the bishop
back to C6 so the bishop pair uh doing
uh a fine job keeping that Rook at Bay
with Ponte A5 now this is a very strong
move uh and King to F7 uh ding starts
bringing the king into the game we have
Rook the E2 now threatening to win the
pawn here and just Knight the C1
attacking the rook and here uh Believe
It or Not Rook the E1 was played and we
have knighted the D3 rookie two knights
the C1 Rook to E1 and knights the D3 and
he was in this position on move 39 that
ayani polish and ingleren agreed to a
draw and after 13 games in the world
Chess Championship uh the result is now
uh still a tie so there will be one more
classical game uh we'll see Dean will
have the white pieces we'll see if he
will try to push for the win because he
did have a very nice success with white
pieces either winning or achieving
winning chances or will they just um
settle it peacefully and then we will
have tie breaks like I said I'm happy
with both I would I would very much
enjoy seeing a you know any mortal game
by either of them but I would also enjoy
them going into tie breaks because I'm
I'm really enjoying their games uh uh so
far pretty much all of them
I have been uh really enjoyable maybe
okay that Berlin rod and it didn't
really uh you know uh Inspire anyone to
the the play chess uh but other than
that you know all the other games were
really incredible uh so yeah I hear you
resign because there's no good way to do
it uh he will be okay he will continue
to harass the pawn and the ding will
just um you know keep attacking the rook
and basically none of them wanted
anything to happen in this game ding had
a couple of chances where he could have
pushed for more but uh he just didn't
want to overdo it because he does not
want to lose the uh the penultimate
round and then going into the final
round in a must win situation that would
be that would be a horror so basically
now for ding he's in a world Choice
championship match where uh it's like
you have one classical game you win uh
you you defeat the only promise you with
white in one classical game and you
become the world classical Champion
that's the current situation for ding
now it's the same for nepo only he has
to beat the ding with black in order to
become world champion so I don't know
we'll see what happens will we see will
we see another crazy London or something
I don't think so I think is going to be
uh a pretty calm uh opening but who
knows maybe the the cola system like
being already attempted uh so who who
knows what will happen uh but yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
pretty pretty peaceful uh you know uh
conclusion for for around 13 we'll see
what happens in the final round uh I
would like to thank Kim Tory Jensen
Jacob beat Felipe gorgios uh uh
Grandmaster Thomas rusman and Michael
Kennedy for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World
Chess Championship uh until it finishes
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day